[Musique]
deux informations qui viennent d'être
annoncées par le premier ministre jean
castex
nous allons lever l'obligation générale
du port du masque un extérieur et à
partir de dimanche levée du couvre feu
ces décisions ont été prises au vu de
l'amélioration de la situation sanitaire
plus rapide que prévu les bleus qui
n'ont pas posé le genou à terre hier
avant le coup d'envoi comme on s'y
attendait comme il l'avait déjà fait en
match de préparation un signe de lutte
contre le racisme ça ne s'est donc pas
fait des sportifs peuvent être des
hommes et des femmes engagés avec des
idées j'ai lu une interview très
intéressante qu'il ya des maps et ya
quelques semaines un petit s'est exprimé
je crois que c'est un jeune homme qui a
des convictions je regrette qu'il ne
l'ait pas fait et j'espère que leur
décision de ne pas le faire n'est pas
lié à cette affreuse polémique pas vos
regrets lorsque laurence ferrari en
l'occurrence lutter contre le racisme et
les discriminations
c'est profondément républicain que les
joueurs de foot aient envie d'exprimer
leurs convictions c'est tout à fait
légitime même si c'est pas ça forcément
qu'on attend mais moi je trouve ça tout
à fait légitime mais en revanche pour
lutter contre le racisme mais il faut
pas tomber dans le racialisme qui est
qui est contraire à l'esprit même
républicain qui transforme les origines
elle je suis très heureux d'ailleurs
qu'il se soit ravise et je pense que
c'est une décision sage n'a pas besoin
de polémiques comme ça qu'ils vont
diviser alors qu'on est dans un moment
de communion nationale autour notre
équipe et qu'on souhaite simplement
qu'il gagne pile qu'est ce que vous
reprochez à cette news massart par
exemple vous ont reproché autre chose
oui bien sûr c'est la chaîne c'est la
chaîne de marine le pen oui bien sûr je
suis ici sur une chaîne dont je n'ai pas
de difficulté à dire que de mon point de
vue elle participe d'un agenda
médiatique d'extrême droite que je
trouve délétère et qui ne vous laisserai
pas dire ça c'est pour vous vous avez le
droit de ne pas me laisser le travail de
toute une rédaction avec d'errance
ferrari libre et insulté personne
c'est un choix éditorial teignouse ses
new skies reçoit toutes les sensibilités
politiques est il besoin de le rappeler
bah oui les besoins de leur âge
besoin de le rappeler je les ai rappelés
et j'en suis ici là représentants mais
vous avez regardé travailler moi je suis
face à vous et je vous explique que par
exemple vous ne pouvez pas nier que le
csa a épinglé votre chaîne récemment sur
le pluralisme politique et le fait
d'avoir plutôt offert la parole à les
respecter
ok en attendant mais en attendant est la
preuve vivante désencombrer l'espace
public de la capitale c'est l'objectif
de la mairie en rendant le stationnement
payant aux scooters et motos thermiques
à partir de 2022
c'était hier à angers un match de futsal
entre écologistes avec des ténors d'un
côté en bleu yannick jadot
le député européen julien bayou le
patron des verts delphine batho qui fut
ministre
et puis des locaux les têtes de listes
locales vous allez gazon synthétique
les conducteurs des deux roues ne
décolère pas le patin à roulettes aussi
s'arrêter après lyon le changement de
paca roulotte non méchoui que j'échoue
du monde l'interpellation tôt ce matin
de remy daillet figure des milieux
complotistes soupçonné d'être impliqué
dans l'enlèvement de la petite mia en
avril dernier dans les vosges la
malaisie l'avait expulsé dimanche son
visa ayant expiré
rencontre au sommet aujourd'hui entre
joe biden et vladimir poutine
le 46e président américain est arrivé
hier soir en suisse
je vous souhaite messieurs les
présidents de fructueux dialogue dans
l'intérêt de vos deux pays et du monde
[Musique]
le saas vient de s'ouvrir
il est un peu plus de 14 heures heure de
paris
comme prévu thomas pesquet sort le
premier suivi de son fidèle coéquipier
chaîne kibo 3h30 des changes armement
cybersécurité ukraine droits de l'homme
proche orient les visages sont tendus
les deux hommes avaient prévu de tracer
les lignes rouges de se dire ce qui est
acceptable et ce qui ne l'est pas ils
ont eu une petite frayeur l'ordinateur
du scaphandre de chine kimball
coéquipiers de thomas pesquet a eu une
panne il a fallu faire une mise à jour